ما زالت المعارك مستمره ولا توقف في تبادل
اطلاق النار ما بين الطرفين ان كان على
مستوى المقاطعه هنا في وان كان على مستوى
مدينه باخموت اخر التطورات في مدينه
باخموت هو انسحاب تدريجي وعلى شكل مجموعات
صغيره للقوات الاوكرانيه من الناحيه
الغربيه الشماليه حيث مدينه خرومبا هناك
شهود عيان اكدوا بان القوات الاوكرانيه
بدات تنسح تنسحب من هذا المحور بلده خروما
هي المتاخمه لبلده بغداد
والبعيده عن منطقه كراسنا التي
يعني كائنه على الخط السريع وهو خط الذي
يوصل الامدادات العسكريه للقوات
الاوكرانيه كما اسلفت شهود عيان يؤكدون
بان القوات الاوكرانيه بدات تنسحب من هذه
البلده تدريجيا على شكل مجموع صغيره لكن
المعارك هناك ما زالت مستمره وهناك من هم
يدافعون عن البلده في المحور الغربي حتى
الان بينما تقاتل قوات فاجنر في جميع
المحاور الحديث عن الطوق كنصف هلال وعن
المناطق التي دخلوها اسخن المعارك داخل
المدينه في المنطقه الجنوبيه في محور
سباشكا في هذا المحور ما زالت قوات فاجنر
تحاول التقدم اكثر للوصول الى قلب المدينه
القوات الاوكرانيه ما زالت تدافع وتؤكد
بانها مستمره بالمقاومه هناك محاور اخرى
نايف لا تقل اهميه عن محور باخموت كوبيانس
كعاده القوات الروسيه بعد ان انسحبت من
مناطق كوبيانس كوليمان واصواتها وتمركزت
في كريمنا لفتره طويله منذ اواخر العام
الماضي شهدت هذه الايام عوده للقوات
الروسيه
وتقدم على الارض يعني في اليومين الماضيين
كانت فقط ثلاثه كيلومترات تفصل الجيش
الروسي عن مدينه كوبيانسك اليوم وصلت جيش
الروسي الى تخوم المدينه ويحاول اقتحام
هناك ضربات بالمدفعيه الروسيه وبراجيمات
الصواريخ مع تقدم على الارض للمشاه هناك
خطه عسكريه للجيش الروسي لاستعاده هذه
المدن التي خسرها وفي ذلك الوقت يعني خسر
ثقه المؤيدين للعمليه العسكريه ربما هذه
العوده تعيد الثقه للمواطنين الروس الذين
ايدوا هذه العمليه من بياد من بدايتها اي
ثقتهم بالجيشه وامكاناته بالفعل اذا سمح
الوقت وبعجال اكثر من خمسين الف قذيفه
وصاروخ تضرب من قبل اجانب الروسي على جميع
المحاور يوميا هذا ما يعني بان يعني
التقارير التي تحدثت عنها وزاره الدفاع
البريطانيه بان هناك نقص في الذخيره
الروسيه على الارض وميدانيا يعني لا يتفق
مع هذه التصريحات او على الاقل ينافي ما
قالته وزاره الدفاع البريطانيه وانت صحفي
موجود على الارض تتابع هذه المعركه منذ
بدايتها رائد
في الواقع نايف دائما وانا اتابع تقارير
الدفاع البريطانيه دائما ما تكون قريبه من
الواقع والحقيقه لكن خاصه في هذا التقرير
هذا هو بالفعل لا يتفق مع الواقع على
الارض لان الواقع على الارض لا توقف
للضربات وللقصف المتبادل ومن ناحيه روسيا
بكثافه بالفعل جميع المحاور تشهد تعزيزات
ايضا روسيه تعزيزات بشريه اضافه الى
الاليات وكما اسلفت بان وزاره الدفاع ايضا
الروسيه قالت بانها دمرت عشرات الاليات
والمدافع وصواريخ هايمرز